[Musik]
wasser
herzlichen glückwunsch schon richtig
cool im war schmelz
auflauf richtig easy und ich habe hier
zwei ganz besondere person noch nie da
und zwar diese zwei personen sind die
zwei größten gangster auf der baustelle
einmal den kennt die chance sich nach
asien auf juni so ist auf der anderen
seite mein schwieriger vater
schwiegervater
das habe ich schon gemacht und wie wir
das gemacht haben das zeigen wir euch
jetzt
[Musik]
massiv geschüttelt er sagt deine
schützen
also wahnsinnig was für ein auflauf von
papa der eine sieht und hört nichts und
ich werde dann sehr schädlich sagt du
zum beispiel durch am grauen star oder
papa der hört nichts du hörst
coole sache wurde ich irgendwann mit den
zwei übrigens auf dem bau zu arbeiten
ist eine ganz ganz nützlich geschichte
weilguny schafft es noch langsamer zu
sein als der papa statt 75 er ist nicht
mehr der schnellste aber zunächst noch
langsam
oder tut sich der papa über die
aufregende tage bin ich viel zu langsam
unter und sagte papa geht mir auf den
sack und dann merke ich einfach klingt
ist ohnehin recht müssen bundestrainer
ein gespräch wenn man ja ja genau genau
mit einer nicht da ist dann geht es in
den anderen hinterher ich weiß es so was
wir brauchen ist für den keks boden also
für den auflauf boden da kennt er
inzwischen meine rezepte irgendwie mache
ich immer den gleichen boden keine
ahnung wir brauchen hier keine die von
neben von leitungs original mit 52 10
oder die vom vom lidl ja nur 42 zähne
sondern günstiger
bei 200 grad vollkornkekse ihr könnt
auch andere kekse nehmen die waren wir
uns gerade übrig weil da auch voll
konnten ist und folglich soll davon dann
haben wir hier 60 km brezel die brezel
machen mir weil es ja ziemlich süß ist
dann wir ein bisschen auf einen anderen
geschmack noch einen geringen deswegen
hier die salz plätze da braucht man 60
kann dann brauchen wir 100 gramm butter
und damit haben wir schon boden fertig
dann brauche nachher für den auflauf
brauchen wir 350 gramm marshmallows so
diese maschine das gibt es inzwischen
überall eigentlich auch ohne schweini
platine dann haben wir hier schon gelten
aber ihr könnt auch was anderes der show
gegner es ist keine geschmackssache und
was wir noch hier haben sind 200 gramm
frische erdbeeren himbeeren vom bauern
klaus genau so papa wir machen jetzt
zuerst im boden ok den keks boden denn
tun wir hier eine auflaufform richtig
schön schichten und ich weiß du bist du
bist ja früher ein rasenmäher steht
jetzt genau was auf panama das klischee
aber
diese menschen komische man ja noch
einmal senken diesem angenommen immerhin
über mich
wenn man warum hast du ihn genommen also
warum diese man ja noch bestimmt viel
lügen oder blah blah blah blah
nicht leben
auch wenn der schwiegervater sagte
[Gelächter]
er habe nach den backofen vorheizen
genau backen vor 1 genau zum 83 grad war
es sowieso schlauer mensch wirklich die
schlauen fuchs papa diese menschlich
funktion überlegen ist als ich und du
sollst du kriegst klein precious uns
völlig blockiert wieder nein wirtschaft
passt also ober unterhitze 180 grad
vorheizen
dann ist der papa in die falle laufen
wird nein also hier haben wir den gegner
2310 okay geben ich fest von zehn
richtig die macht
aber mir gelang minister offenbar über
die baustelle gearbeitet habe es ist
cool ist immer jeden tag da und helfen
uns auf der baustelle
bei lewis ab dem 1 in seinem alter
entweder falsch frage anzeigen und
tauben füttern oder hier bei uns helfen
aber dann geschah etwas
aber diese über den präsidenten
beleidigen darf nicht mehr in die türkei
reisen
doch stehen ich nenne ich mal wirklich
und dass ich so auflaufen ist auch dass
das so läuft und dann hier die
möglichkeit vier wochen den frauenknast
europawahl maschinenbaubereich dort ist
reiches folgen es reicht schon einen
preis dann will ich nicht zu sagen
zerkleinern perfekt aber diese
meinem eindruck man ist ja ja so viel
musik
so jetzt schmelzen die butter ein
fast schon heute backen ist einmal
jährlich zur kugel gemacht rezession
gemalt
er war schon in essen aber gesagt ja
[Gelächter]
aber gebacken gekocht habe schon früher
öfter sondern schon öfter gekommen
doch sowohl die habe als hockeyspieler
martinsmarkt
ich sagen ja diese menschen diese iq von
230 und wieso
diese immer böse zu hoch
ich kann das hat richtig deutsch
sprechen aber ich weiß nicht warum mir
jedes mal so und so komisch sprechen ja
ein kleiner papa ein besseres deutsch
spricht und
ohne der papa können wir das ja alles
gar nicht machen also hilft das wirklich
im garten und und bei allem also auch
beim bau der ist eigentlich fast schon
sieben acht stunden tag hier und
unterstützt schon seit jahren schon seit
45 jahren und wenn ich jetzt kinder
morgens den kindergarten bringen der
papa mittags ab bringt sie her ist echt
cool tolle unterstützung dankbar
unter company und tut alles um archer
einreisen
aber es ist fertig mache ich hier rein
schön viel fett schön viel butter weil
der
gute fette schlecht
aber ich
verstehe was soll ich da mal anrufen
hallo hallo anna murad muwafi lauer
[Musik]
nicht dass die banken ihr ausrichten
papa diese mann gefährlich
risikopatienten aber risiko für uns alle
ist es genau
das jetzt drei monaten augen aufmachen
wo normalerweise kleinkinder macht
papa mir ist aufgefallen ich glaube
diese grüne
was ja
also da der papa ist natürlich aus einer
anderen generation
andere generationen aber
gar nie genau so ein kaputter generation
und ich mache mit der du machst
und so arbeiten wie ganztag jetzt mit
zwei arbeiten wie ich denke deshalb
beide haben schlaganfall gleichzeitig
wirklich da gibt eine zeit lang gar
nichts
[Musik]
langsam arbeitete aber langsam aber da
bin ich froh dass ich keine gewinne
erzielen muss so langsam ihre zwei sein
egal
so okay jetzt haben wir das gemacht
jetzt mal auf folgendes papa eine ganz
ganz einfache arbeit das macht er ja
eigentlich so hat das jahrelang 29 jahre
lang hat er so gearbeitet er hat ein
schrauben sortiert und zwar kommen ist
jetzt man immer eine reine schokolade
eine himbeere eine schokolade eine
himbeere okay
schokolade wer schokolade hast du
verstanden ja okay alles
macht jetzt beide hoffen kann man jetzt
hier auch so
genau und da könnte wirklich jede
schokolade oder jede frucht nehmen auf
der big box ab aber gerade hier ist es
ganz cool wieder nimmt hier eine zarte
schokolade das ist nicht zu süß wird
aber wie immer beim denken ja
überlegen wie sollte ich müde spielen
sollte das ding da machen
[Musik]
dafür dass im café heraus wenn ich kann
mir das handy anschauen bei den 2 es
sieht aus als würde dir zwar ein puzzle
machen sie das
paul hat ist der erste kuchen den du
selber gebacken hat wahnsinn oder hast
du das in einem jahren noch mal
mitbekommen hast
aber du bist schneller als kimi und für
die noch 20 jahre jünger ist
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir hier die marshmallows und
wie gesagt vor und die gibt es wirklich
ohne schweine die gibt es wirklich im
türkischen markt in arabischen markt
wurde keine ahnung wo aber auch beim
lieben gibt es ja auch ohne schweine
finanzieren so
und jetzt können wir ein machen und
einfach aufstellen okay aber
durch das helle sich die ideale kuchen
für euch zweigen ist so eine richtige
beschäftigung für euch
beschäftigungstherapie für rentner und
der papa der ist schon seit paris schon
jetzt bis zu 75 richtig 575 aber seit
zehn jahren rente ja richtig kann man ja
ja ne
du kommst die rente und dann sahen wir
da auf die welt gekommen perfekt war
alles geplant
aber ich stolz auf mein schwiegersohn ja
natürlich
war noch mal der strom die pflanzen
tiere und danach konnte ich und dann
kommt mensch
dem schrauber ist anna kusch 1090
natürlich kommt es auf die größere
auflaufform ihr können wir jede
auflaufform benutzen ob klassisch oder
im mai letztlich will ich will dich egal
aber ab morgen ich weg dann nur noch
tourist
da kannst du dein geld in maschinen
nicht mehr baustelle ja nichts mehr
baustellen gesagt jetzt aufgestiegen ja
vorher baustelle und jetzt koch expertin
wer mit und günni das passt perfekt
jetzt haben wir jetzt haben die zwei
hier das fertig gemacht
was man übrigens aufgefallen ist wenn
ihr die marshmallows in wega nimmt und
anstatt der butter die pflanzen
margarine nimmt ist es bisher schwer
vegan
auch funktion mit der ganzen meinung
obwohl die butterkekse
vergisst einfach denkt kann ich nur nach
sagen wir jetzt immer einfach das ding
und tools 20 minuten bei 180° unter
oberhitze lassen wir es im backofen
richtig kusch morgen deswegen kommt es
wird auch
auflaufen okay okay
[Musik]
so sieht's jetzt aus um ihr probiert
jetzt mal wird zwei problem bei der
partner kann ich probieren weil der papa
der fastet und
erst morgen genau dass du wieder
probieren hat das trotzdem mitgeholfen
richtig cool da ging fast nichts weil
wenn ihr fasten würde wieder nicht so
aussehen und ich faste nicht weil ich
einfach medikamente nehme ich dachte ich
ja ich sag nicht welche
für familien gebeten ja genau auf jeden
fall
diese mensch probiert jetzt du na ja ich
hab ja ja ja
schon naja also du machst du machst das
immer doktorarbeit raus ging nicht immer
so einfach geht es tag rein und dann
nimmst du das leere spatel rein
ich glaube dass ich noch zu heiß ist ein
bisschen warten noch wir warten noch ein
bisschen als wäre es ein großer fehler
wir warten das abgekühlt hat werde ich
echt noch ziemlich heiß es gibt
verschiedene varianten dass er vergessen
kann wie gesagt diese aufhalten coole
party auflauf bin jetzt nicht die
pandemie gewesen wäre würde ich sagen
alle man hinten rein und raus holen das
machen wir natürlich nicht mehr
da heißt nicht mehr in one auf dem
fleisch brett war das ding sondern dass
hier zum beispiel in der küche im small
scale was auch geht ist ihr könnt zum
beispiel kekse nehmen und mit den keksen
hier einfach das ding
rausholen
wahnsinn
warum ich
das wäre echt gut aber
ich muss zugeben ich
voll süß
damit hat der boden
es klebt ich habe anstatt bei der
dritten dann hängen bleiben
haben wir uns gerüstet
nein ich bin ich dankbar diese man immer
gewalt
die ausländer
haben im löffelrein
aus wie gestanden hat
nichts hasst stalingrad gesagt
wie dresden eine bombe angst aufkommen
viele sagen jetzt ist es mal probiert
das sei aber ehrlich auf heißt
deswegen das abkühlen lassen aber jetzt
ich glaube wenn unten diese himbeer und
diese salzbrezeln sind schmeckt gar
nicht so ding
ja mit im bett gegangen
wenn er nicht nur die marshmallows ist
ist nicht so süß also ist auch das
unternehmen stabil 50 grad gut
wenn die kohle geschichte für ein
kindergeburtstag
wenn ihr natürlich wollte ich ihn an die
küsten macht es ist ja dass sein dass du
als kind oft von den us-stars ich glaube
du hast du schon öfters gemacht oder
ganze seiten auflaufen hammer
richtigkeit hin zu hause machen einen
ganz ganz wie sie macht auch was von
optik ja papa danke dass ihr mich
unterstützt habt
wissen zoller schwiegervater und
da freuen ja du bist ein toller freund
ein ganz toller freundin ja du bist so
toll dass das so gar
nicht was ich gegen was schon gegessen
habe dich sehen möchte jaja wiedersehen
[Gelächter]
wichtigsten daumen nach oben war richtig
cool und hält nicht mich hätte die
anderen durch die sage vom
schwiegervater ok macht's gut in schuss
aber mit den kanal voll wichtig ganz ab
und den kanal ist nicht unser aber egal
es aber wieder auf die baustellen
arbeiten
aber kommen wir
heute mal pause